Selam i'm Jamshid l Jamshid e and this
is a Mideast minute villagers thank you
for tuning in as always from the middle
east today as we broadcast to you live
from portland the hometown of a number
of peacekeepers with opec cutting oil
production in an effort to boost the
slumping price of crude it's time for
the middle east to realize that oil is
overrated oil the black pus of the
planet squeezed out from the ground is
from the face of a teenage boy and the
real reason why cute planets don't pay
us attention for years the middle east
has relied on oil for everything from
fuel to asphalt to bonfires but has it
been worth it an unequivocal no when you
remove money power and women from the
equation so cut your losses and move on
villagers transition to a more stable
economy centered on food wine and
tourism after all what's there to lose
half a trillion in revenue sure but what
else centering your economy on your rich
history and beautiful sights is a
surefire way to replace that revenue
with something better
dignity because instead of polluting the
planet
you'll be whoring it out and it wouldn't
be the world's oldest profession if it
wasn't respected so pull the trigger
make the switch move on and if you're
wondering what to do with your oil
fields when you're done leave that to us
we've got a long history of turning
surplus land into something mutually
beneficial i'm Jamshid al-jabr GD and
this has been a Mideast minute